schönen guten Morgen
Nessler das war ja wichtig dass da
gestern diskutiert wurde in der Sache
allerdings wenig Neues muss man sagen
Argumente die man schon kannte die
Opposition schiebt der ampelregierung
die Schuld zu dass sie keinen eigenen
Antrag haben also wie gesagt da wurden
die alten Argumente ausgetauscht in der
Sache nicht viel Neues der entscheidende
Punkt ist aber ob so eine Impfpflicht
wenn sie denn kommen würde überhaupt
verfassungskonform wäre
da haben sie recht das ist tatsächlich
der entscheidende Punkt die Politik ist
frei aber sie muss sich an die Grenzen
der Verfassung halten und aus meiner
Sicht ist tatsächlich die
impfpflichtverfassungswidrig sie ist
eben kein kleiner Pieks wie manchmal
gesagt wir sollen sie sagen deutlicher
Eingriff in ganz viele Grundrechte nicht
nur in das Grundrecht der körperlichen
Unversehrtheit auch in andere
Grundrechte und das erlaubt die
Verfassung nur unter besonderen
Bedingungen und diese Bedingungen sehe
ich im Augenblick nicht als gegeben an
reicht denn ihrer Meinung nach das
Argument eines überlasteten
Gesundheitssystems was es ja auch
momentan gar nicht gibt
das sind sozusagen zwei Punkte der erste
Punkt ist ja die Verfassung gesagt dem
Staat du hast die Pflicht die Gesundheit
und das Leben auch deiner BürgerInnen
und Bürgerin zu schützen insofern muss
der Staat eine
ein funktionierendes Gesundheitssystem
unterhalten aber die Frage ist ob die
impfpflichter für überhaupt geeignet ist
eine mögliche wir reden ja nicht von der
tatsächlichen Überlastung sondern von
einer möglichen Überlastung des
Gesundheitssystems
das Problem ist glaube ich seit Omegon
sind die Spielregeln anders die Impfung
wirkt fast gar nicht mehr gegen Omegon
das sieht man an Zahlen
gucken sich Portugal an oder Bremen das
sind zwei Staaten die haben eine
unglaublich hohe Impfquote da gibt es
praktisch keine impflücke und trotzdem
gehen die Inzidenzen durch die Decke das
heißt möglicherweise sind die Impfstoffe
die wir gerade haben gar nicht geeignet
das Ziel zu erreichen nämlich die
Ansteckung zu verhindern und dann darf
man natürlich die Bürger nicht mit einer
Pflicht belegen sich dann trotzdem
impfen zu lassen und dann bleibt noch
die Frage sollte eine Impfpflicht kommen
wie kann die überhaupt kontrolliert
werden
sie haben auch recht eine Pflicht nützt
nur das nur dann was wenn man sie auch
kontrollieren kann und das ist natürlich
ganz schwierig
wir müssten der Staat müsste dann wissen
welcher Bürger welche Bürgerin hat sich
wie oft impfen lassen das würde ein
unglaublich umfangreiches impfregister
erfordern über ganz sensible
Gesundheitsdaten wir reden ja nicht über
irgendwelche Daten sondern wir reden da
über intime Gesundheitsdaten und das
kann man denke ich praktisch schon gar
nicht in der Kürze der Zeit aufbauen und
was den Datenschutz angeht der ja auch
von der Verfassung garantiert wird halte
ich das für ganz problematisch einfach
unglaublich viele intime persönliche
Daten zusammen dass das sehe ich gerade
nicht wie das gehen soll Einordnungen
von Professor böhmen-nessler vielen Dank
dafür
ich danke Ihnen